[Music]
on this tuesday night the ukrainian
president's impassioned plea to prime
minister justin trudeau severe explosion
justin can you imagine hearing his
powerful message every night is a
horrible night and his criticism of nato
keem under siege and under curfew the
new deadly assaults
and a new show of support in ukraine
defiance and dissent a russian
journalist resurfaces after protesting
the invasion it was really terrible and
kremlin propaganda and a major dustup
why spain suddenly looks like mars
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight david aiken
good evening and thank you for joining
us keeve's mayor has placed ukraine's
capital city under a curfew after
another fatal bombing in a residential
neighborhood
ukraine emergency services says
civilians were killed after numerous
buildings were struck by missile attacks
more on the situation on the ground in a
minute but first canada has imposed new
sanctions on 15 russian officials that
are accused of helping vladimir putin
invade ukraine and the kremlin has fired
back by banning prime minister justin
trudeau and others from entering russia
all of this comes on the same day that
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
delivered a speech directly to the
canadian parliament abigail beeman has
more on his message and how the
government is responding
rare all-party unity supporting the
ukrainian president's address to
parliament in a house of commons more
packed than at any time since the
pandemic began
[Applause]
can you imagine famous cn tower in
toronto
if they if it was hit by
russian bombs in a 12-minute address
volodomir zalenski tried to bring the
heartbreaking situation facing his
people even closer to canadians calling
on the prime minister by name
imagine that on the
on 4 am each of you
you start hearing bomb explosions
severe explosion justin can you imagine
hearing
you your children hear all these severe
explosions
bombing of airport bombing of ottawa
airport mps senators and about 200
guests in the public gallery heard
zielinski confirmed the fighting has
already killed 97 ukrainian children
and while the ukrainian president
acknowledged canada is leading
international efforts to help he was
critical of allies who won't declare a
no-fly zone over his country
can you imagine when you
when you call your friends your friendly
nation and you ask
please close the sky
close the airspace please stop the
bombing how many more cruise missiles
have to fall on our cities
until you
make this happen
and they in return they express their
deep concerns close the skies work with
nato figure out how we can make it work
ukrainian canadians watching were moved
by the speech and the gravity of the
moment it was really powerful it was
jaw dropping it was amazing to be a part
of all that we'll probably only
understand how historic this day
actually is
in years to come his appeal to the
ukrainian canadian diaspora of course
was very heartfelt and we want him to
know that we are fighting hand and fist
to assist ukraine it is our moral duty
party leaders responded to the prime
minister spoke ahead of zolensky i've
always thought of you as a champion for
democracy
and now
democracies around the world are lucky
to have you
as our champion and where there aren't
adequate tools by god let's invent them
and my parliamentary bureau colleague
abigail beeman joins me now abigail we
were both there in the house of commons
an extraordinary day in parliament what
stood out to you
david it was really that sense of all
party unity of everyone coming together
in such a historic moment you and i both
haven't seen the house that full in in
more than two years with a packed public
gallery as well there was so much
applause and standing ovations and not
just for president zielenski but for
party leaders of all stripes as well
we heard from elizabeth mann your piece
what did the other opposition leaders
have to say after the speech
well what really stood out were comments
from the interim conservative leader
candace bergin the only party the
conservative party to be talking about a
no-fly zone we must do more together
with our allies to secure ukraine's
airspace we need to protect at a minimum
the airspace over the humanitarian
corridors
candace bergen isn't exactly calling for
a full no-fly zone over ukraine but a
partial one to protect ukrainians who
want to leave war-torn areas safely and
to get humanitarian aid in meanwhile the
block leader called for more weapons for
ukraine the ndp leader for more
sanctions on russia and more
humanitarian aid and the prime minister
announced another 15 russians would be
sanctioned today as well and of course
almost as soon as zielinski had finished
his speech we saw a release from the
russian foreign ministry that justin
trudeau and others are to be banned from
russia what can you tell us about that
well canada has consistently been
announcing new sanctions against russia
and now we see russia firing back with
this list of
313 canadians who are banned from
entering russia it's mostly mps so the
prime minister defense minister anita
anand foreign affairs minister melanie
jolie and then there are close to two
dozen other names on that list everyone
from the chief of the defense staff to
the head of fintrac members of the
ukrainian canadian congress and half a
dozen people involved with the planning
of a memorial here in ottawa for victims
of communism russia isn't just targeting
canada here there are also new sanctions
a shorter list against americans
including president joe biden david
all right abigail beeman here in ottawa
thank you
the united kingdom issued hundreds of
new sanctions against the russian
president's allies the british
government says it is targeting people
who are propping up vladimir putin and
helping facilitate the invasion of
ukraine it's estimated those individuals
have a net worth of approximately
166 billion dollars canadian new
legislation was required to pass this
round of sanctions
the ukrainian capital is now under a
35-hour curfew after another day of
russian bombardments at least four
people were killed in kiev the mayor
says the city faces a quote difficult
and dangerous moment as russian troops
edge closer in the south the heart-hit
port city of mariupol is surrounded
though some civilians managed to escape
today as redmond shannon reports those
left behind face a worsening situation
a deadly night of shelling in
that many in ukraine's capital fear may
become all too common right now everyone
is angry i talk to the people they don't
want to leave they really upset what
what russian soldier do it with sydney
homes are destroyed buildings in ruins
and a blanket curfew is now in effect
until at least thursday
in anticipation of further attacks we'd
like to
ask you to help yourself by helping us
president vladimir zielinski continued
his appeal to european leaders for more
arms
destruction in the second city of
harkev2 normally home to one and a half
million people
this resident who describes himself as
russian says he doesn't need weapons
you want to fight putin come find me
black belt i could tear you apart with
my bare hands he says
in besieged mario paul more civilians
escaped in some 2000 cars tuesday but
ukraine says russia is again blocking
aid from entering we're essentially
being suffocated in this city right now
with no aid the eu says at least 2400
civilians have been killed here so far
we know of families who are undoing oil
heaters to take water coolant out as a
last resort as something to drink the
regional governor says 400 patients and
staff are effectively being held hostage
by russian troops in this now damaged
hospital
further to the west russia claims it now
controls all of kersen region
anger and sadness are only mounting
ukrainians mourning some of the 1300
soldiers the government says have been
killed so far that number will surely
rise as the latest round of peace talks
have again failed to produce any obvious
progress
redmond shannon global news london
and the number of people fleeing ukraine
has been rising steadily since the
invasion began nearly three weeks ago
the united nations refugee agency says
three million people have fled to
neighboring countries since february the
24th poland has taken in the vast
majority more than 1.8 million people
followed by romania and moldova
nato will convene a special summit in
brussels next week to discuss russia and
ukraine world leaders including u.s
president joe biden will be there the
high-level talks come as pressure mounts
for the coalition to do more to stop
russian aggression ukraine's president
is pleading for a no-fly zone and as
heather urex west reports at least one
nato country is publicly supporting the
idea despite the risk of war with russia
[Music]
as misery compounds in ukraine nato's
secretary general called world leaders
once again to brussels president putin's
brutal invasion of ukraine is causing
death
and destruction every day
an extraordinary summit will be held in
europe next week as pressure melts for
the coalition to do more to stop the
bloodshed
on monday the parliament of estonia
passed a resolution calling for the
no-fly zone ukraine so desperately seeks
making it the first nato country to take
a public stand while tuesday the leaders
of poland the czech republic and
slovenia traveled to kiev putting
themselves at risk in a show of
solidarity as russian forces continue
their advance towards the city i'm
impressed by their bravery i also would
say that it's not going to be a game
changer because
ultimately these countries can't really
provide anything like a no-fly zone the
majority of nato's member countries
remain opposed to a no-fly zone knowing
it will be seen by russia as an
escalation beyond ukraine's borders the
no-fly zone
which often people shorthand essentially
means us shooting down russian planes
and them potentially shooting back at us
but nearly three weeks into the bloody
conflict the russian president has shown
no signs of backing down i think it is
important for the west to deal very
directly with
in some way
with the nuclear blackmail that if putin
gets away with nuclear blackmail in this
case he will try to use it in the future
nato has also raised concerns that
russia may stage false flag attacks in
ukraine using chemical weapons whether
that's a red line is something nato
leaders will have to address when they
meet in belgium next week david
heather urex west in washington tonight
thank you heather
two more journalists have been killed in
ukraine after a vehicle they were
traveling in came under fire outside
keeve veteran war photographer and fox
news camera person pierre schuszewski
and ukrainian journalist alexandra sasha
kushnova who was assisting the fox news
crew both died in the attack fox news
correspondent benjamin hall was also
injured and he remains in hospital
a russian journalist has been fined and
released from custody after interrupting
a live tv news broadcast to protest
against the war in ukraine marina
oceanicova is an editor and producer at
one of russia's state-run tv networks as
ross lord reports despite the
consequences her actions may be
inspiring others
it took courage for marina obsi anakova
to protest vladimir putin's invasion of
ukraine storming the set of one of
russia's most popular news programs with
a poster reading in russian stop the war
don't believe the propaganda they are
lying to you here the moment spread
quickly around the world the risk of
going to prison or worse is very real in
a country that just legislated even
tighter restrictions on journalists and
freedom of expression there could be
retaliation against your family
this is a regime the vladimir putin
regime
that has not hesitated to use the
harshest possible measures against
dissent
family members and supporters feared the
worst after oceana kova disappeared into
police custody for nearly 24 hours with
the kremlin calling her actions
hooliganism she says police interrogated
her extensively for 14 hours and she
wasn't allowed a lawyer or to contact
her family she's been fined not for the
on-air protest but for a separate video
statement urging others to protest
wearing a necklace with the colors of
the ukraine flag her father's home
country she's not backing down it was my
own
decision
yeah if i made this decision by myself
because i
uh
don't like
[Music]
russia starts this invasion what's
happening in ukraine is a crime she says
and russia is the aggressor ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has singled
out austriana kova who also has two
children for praise since she spoke out
a growing number of prominent
journalists have reportedly left their
positions at russian state media
including lilia gildieva a leading tv
anchor who'd been praised by putin
gildieva has fled russia the bravery of
these people is absolutely extraordinary
because they don't know it would have
the effect that they hope for
but they act out of principle he says
they could be seen as heroes if the
russian invasion fails
or forgotten if putin succeeds
ross lord global news
it has been months since four members of
a muslim family were killed in london
ontario coming up what court documents
now suggest about the alleged attacker
and global national is broadcasting from
the nation's capital tonight we're back
in a moment
there is new information tonight
outlining the police investigation into
the deaths of a muslim family in london
ontario in june of 2021.
four members of the ufsall family died
after being run over by the driver of a
pickup truck as mike delay reports new
court documents reveal the alleged
attacker may have been radicalized on
the dark web
nine months after four members of the
assault family were killed in london
ontario while out for an evening walk
very little is still publicly known
about their alleged attacker nathaniel
veltman had a small footprint on social
media with only a few photos existing
online of the now 21 year old
newly released court documents show
investigators have scoured development's
digital storage devices for internet
browsing data communications documents
videos and pictures in a bid to learn
more about the motivations of the
alleged attacker and evidence of advance
planning a sweeping publication ban
still covers many details of the
investigation however the new
information does reveal police found
documents that appear to be hate related
material and relevant to the listed
offenses global news has previously
reported that several sources familiar
with the investigation have said that
veltman was influenced by the gunman who
attacked a pair of mosques in new
zealand in 2019 and the documents show
police searching for evidence of motive
and planning through development's
possible activity on the dark web which
can be used to hide illegal activity in
an email to global news feldman's lawyer
christopher hicks wrote investigators
may have searched for evidence that mr
veltman had shown an interest in the
dark web as many in the republican party
apparently have but there is no evidence
of actual successful contact by mr
veltman
indeed security experts say it's
extremely hard to track browsing history
through what are known as tor browsers
if it happens that someone has been
involved in crimes and um there's all
kinds of other evidence around that then
the presence of torah may indicate
something related to how they're trying
to avoid scrutiny but but just having
the torah browser
shouldn't be in of itself a
scarlet letter feltman faces four counts
of first-degree murder and one count of
attempted murder of the afzal's
nine-year-old boy who survived the
attack feltman also has been charged
with murder terrorist activity he has
yet to enter a plea and his next court
date is in april mike derlay global news
toronto
and still ahead why parts of spain are
seeing orange
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
this is not a filter you are looking at
the sky in southeastern spain turned
orange by
dust it's the impact of strong wind from
a storm that scooped up sand from the
sahara desert the sandstorm could reach
as far north as the netherlands and
northwestern germany
canada's governor general was in london
today meeting with queen elizabeth and
members of the royal family mary simon
and her husband attended tea with the
queen at windsor castle it is their
second official meeting the pair also
met with the prince of wales and duchess
of cornwall at clarence house
you mentioned that someone is next
zalensky's passionate plea to canada in
a historic speech to parliament
global national returns from ottawa
right after this break
back to our top story now nearly three
weeks into russia's invasion ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky delivered a
powerful speech to the house of commons
here is more of his call to action his
vow to prevail and the words of support
for ukraine from this country's
parliamentarians
vladimir in the years i've known you
i've always thought of you as a champion
for democracy
and now
democracies around the world are lucky
to have you
as our champion
[Applause]
can you imagine
that every day you receive
memorandums about the number of
casualties including among women and
children
can you imagine famous cn tower in
toronto
if they if it was hit by
russian bombs
of course i don't wish this on anyone
but this is our reality this war of
naked aggression has revealed vladimir
putin for what he really is
a warmonger and a violent predator with
no regard for human life and suffering
ukrainians are saying we will not back
down we will not give up and we are so
incredibly inspired by them for their
fight for democracy for their fight for
freedom
we want to live
and we want to be victorious
we want to
prevail for the sake of life
and i'm
confident that together we will overcome
and will be victorious
glory to ukraine thank you to canada
[Music]
[Applause]
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm david aiken
we leave you tonight with images from
immersive shivchenko soul of ukraine
this is an exhibit happening today only
in toronto brings to life the work of
ukraine's most renowned artist and poet
terrace shivchenko 100 of the ticket
sales will be donated to relief efforts
for ukraine once again thank you so much
for watching
have a good night
[Music]
[Applause]